hi guys has gone here wishing you all a
very very happy New Year and here's to
great 20 20 now what a year 2019 has
been and we are talking to you live from
this incredible 24 hours to hell in fact
set which starts literally days from now
here are some of the things I'm very
thankful for this year look at you
pretend you my wife right so I'd like to
take this moment and apologize for
absolutely nothing
have a happy healthy delicious 2020 now
do me a favor dying to taste this need
some hats baby do you honestly think you
need hot sauce on my burger are you
kidding me yes sir I arranged for the
Tower Bridge to open up especially for
your arrival
exactly and our on Sanchez was in the
freakin toilet anyway who's number one
he was in the bathroom doing a number
two no the number one number two it was
a [ __ ]
welcome to Ramsay in ten where I'm
challenges are my favorite chef to prove
that all you need to make a stunning
dish is literally 10 minutes with some
amazing greets hello my god
oh my lord now go for a run become legs
of worms this is our own take on spam
that we make with heritage pork so you
give me the [ __ ] spam stop and that
we're gonna do now a beautiful how come
black beautiful they are hand dives
do you see it it's right there sounds
like something out of Vegas spam and
snap
it's the first time I've actually seen
all my car Enrique I learned on the
track how nice amazing I was the last
time I missed that I'm I grated a little
bit of cheese on my [ __ ]
I forgot the goat cheese that's the
secret ingredient and you share the name
with another famous out on Sanchez a
basketball player look a baseball
players oh yeah I better get that ready
it's too many sports until they get
number 9 this is a very which I've
forgotten about I'm joking now here we
are but most importantly um thank you to
you guys the fans because you have been
amazing in fact across 20 19 you show me
so much support we're now up to 12
million followers and we've just gone
past our 2 billion views on YouTube so
that's because of you guys I'll continue
making those incredible videos and watch
and based on all the support you give me
20 20 Happy New Year
Hulk waits for an exciting year ahead
god bless and lots of love